but changing the world can happen
anywhere and anyone can do it so what
starts here can indeed change the world
but the question is
what will the world look like after you
change it
that was now retired four-star Navy
Admiral Willie mcraven in 2014
encouraging college graduates to lead
the Next Generation towards a better
future Admiral mcraven's nearly 40-year
military career included time as a Navy
SEAL and Commander of all U.S Special
Operations forces he advised President
George W bush and Barack Obama and is
best known for overseeing the raid that
ended with the death of Osama bin Laden
his new book is called the wisdom of the
bullfrog leadership made simple but not
easy he writes about lessons he learned
over decades as a leader Admiral William
mcraven good to see you again good to be
here thanks so this book is called the
leadership the wisdom of the bullfrog
what does it mean to be a bullfrog so
the bullfrog is the title given to the
longest serving Navy SEAL on active duty
so in 2011 I was given the title of the
bullfrog but remember we are first and
foremost maybe frogmen so when you are
the oldest serving of the longest
serving frog man you are the bullfrog so
so what I love about this book is that
you've got The Usual Suspects like Von
closet and mokti the Elder not to be
confused with multi the younger but but
you also have Taylor Swift that you
quote you also have Oprah Winfrey that
you quote in the book but I was really
moved by the chapter on when it's time
to command you command and I was
relaying to your story when I was an
Army Cadet in at Fort Bragg North
Carolina and I ran I took my platoon
directly into the line of a sniper fire
this is simulated obviously and I got a
satisfactory by the Cadre officer and he
said you know rather than sitting down
while the sniper was taking pot shots at
you you ran you made a decision and you
told your team to execute that decision
it moved me what you wrote about explain
what Nimitz faced during the Battle of
Midway yeah so this the story takes
place in 1942 June 1942 and uh and
Nimitz is debating whether or not he's
going to move the Pacific Fleet to
engage the Japanese at Midway and and
the intelligence is not very clear so he
is yeah has the the real anxiety of what
should I do which I I do he goes to
visit Admiral Bull Halsey who is in the
hospital and Bull Halsey was notoriously
kind of gruff and and he's kind of
confiding to Halsey that uh he just
doesn't know what to do and Halsey turns
to him and says sir you told me one time
when in command command and the point
being when you're in charge when you're
the leader you have to take decisive
steps sometimes you know you have to be
prepared to make decisions the rank and
file want you to show them that you have
a plan they want you to be decisive and
sometimes even when your decisions are
wrong they will appreciate the fact that
you moved out with you know a certain
amount of confidence and that's that's
the point of that chapter let me ask you
a question about when you're in
leadership how do you keep from getting
insulated and isolated people live in
their bubbles now they do how do you
fight that to make sure you're getting
good information so you can make that
call yeah so it really does the
culture's got to start at the top so as
a leader you've got to make sure that
the men and women that work for you
under understand that you're prepared to
hear bad news and and you've got to do
that by when your staff comes together
you let them know look if I'm doing
something wrong if I'm about to walk
into a Minefield whether it's it's a
virtual or realistic then please tell me
engage me if you do not do that if you
create kind of a toxic work environment
people are afraid to come to you then
you're going to make a lot of mistakes
because your people aren't telling you
ground truth now despite your
accomplishments uh highly respected
highly decorated you're you say that
you're still learning how to be a better
leader yeah how is that well every
single day I mean the fact of the matter
is Nate is you well know no matter what
you're doing every single day you better
be prepared to learn yeah and and
Leadership is a journey and so every
single day I mean when I was a Navy SEAL
when I ran the University of Texas
system uh even today outside of both of
those Realms I'm learning I'm learning
from my students I teach at the
University of Texas LBJ School I learn
from my Millennials and gen Z's how to
be a better leader so yeah you learn
every single day and I want to know what
you learned in that raid to kill Osama
Bin Laden because you said there were
165 phases that went into the planning
every possible scenario was explored how
did that change you well you know
fortunately by the time the raid comes
along I had been a Navy SEAL for a very
long time and you know you've got to do
a couple things one it's going to be
risky so you want to work hard to plan
the risk out of it the fact the matter
is uh you know they never show up in the
movies they never talk about in the
books but about three quarters of the
mission is spent planning because you
want to kind of reduce the risk to the
least possible level but then you also
have to trust the men and women that
work for you you know you've got to give
them the right tools do the job you got
to give them the training to do the job
and then you've got to give them the
latitude to go out and do the job and I
I trusted the men that were working for
me on that mission and obviously they uh
they did what was expected now uh you
know there's so many reasons why people
should read this book but chapter 10 is
one of my favorites I'm not necessarily
A Swifty Yeah by Taylor Swift I know
it's hardcore it's everything just
because you made a good plan doesn't
mean that's what's going to happen right
and that's the chapter no plan survives
first contact with the Enemy that is
powerful and how how much is that
important to you that you have to
understand that a good plan doesn't
always work initially well and in fact
the story starts off with me as a navy
midshipman and and this was the
multi-reference the fact of the matter
is you learned very early on in the
military that no plan you can make the
best plan in the world but the enemy
gets a vote and so no plan survives
first contact with the Enemy Admiral
mcraven always great to have you sir
thank you very much the wisdom of the
bullfrogs is on sale today we'll be
right back